there was a disabled comedian that was
working at the lab factory one time and
it took him a while to get up and it
took him a little while to get off
and i was next and i said man i feel bad
i'm in that dude's parking spot
hello everyone hola mis amigos you're
listening to oh my god
hola with me george lopez
let's do the show
that
you know george is oh i'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
george
george lopez oh my god omg
hey everybody this is producer grant
here just a reminder if you like the
show if you're enjoying the show please
like comment subscribe on any platform
you're checking it out on whether that's
on youtube whether that's apple podcast
spotify anything any engagement that we
have really really helps we all serve
the almighty algorithm these days and
any amount that you sort of interact
with the show in any way just really
helps us out helps us get cooler guests
for the show helps raise the profile for
the show helps give us more content for
you guys to enjoy so thanks again for
checking it out and please enjoy the
episode
this podcast is sponsored by better help
online therapy they offer video phone
and even live chat sessions with your
therapist
see why over 2 million people have used
better help listeners get 10 off their
first month at betterhelp.com
omghi that's b e t t e r h e l p
dot com
slash
o m g
hi
hang on we gotta call will smith yeah
hang on
smoking weed doesn't have to burn
and for the smoothest coldest and
biggest hits you gotta check out today's
sponsor freeze pipe freeze pipe makes a
unique line of freezable pipes bubblers
bongs and more
scientifically engineered to cool smoke
by over 300 degrees you can expect a
smoother and bigger hit
without the intense coughing and throat
burn with 420 sales going on this is
freeze pipe's biggest sale of the year
visit thefreezepipe.com
to check out these killer deals or use
the code omg high for 10 that's
the
freezepipe.com and code omg hi
for 10
off
you know what freeze pipe is like it's
versus going to get a manicure pedicure
versus doing it at home yourself you can
get higher
better cooler
with freeze pipe
how many cats do you have uh is that one
up top there how many cats do you have
i have two oh yeah she's in the picture
yeah and are you a dog person or are you
a cat person
i like cats and dogs i just only own
cats because uh touring all the time
it's a lot harder to take care of a dog
you know cats are like little chicano
kids you can leave them for 10 days and
come back
and they've eaten they've created them
they're you know my grandparents went to
mexico for a month they left me
25 which is not even a dollar like in
ethiopia what was it back in sudan oh it
was like 55 cents a day i think they
probably said a kid can survive on 55
cents a day they left me 25 for the
whole month
who in your family has is there is there
is there professional athletes in your
family
um so my my parents met playing in a
professional foosball tournament
so that's why this whole tour i'm on is
called the hustler tour because i play
foosball too and now i hustle people
after shows on the road at fooseball so
yeah but i mean i don't know if you
would consider that
i mean i consider them to be
professional athletes but i'm sure a lot
of people would not consider
professional football players to be
athletes what what what could
what would determine somebody being a
professional at
like is there a foosball league or not
or is there a
there
is is there
yes so there's a whole um ranking system
where when you go to the national
tournaments if you place high enough in
certain events then you your ranking
moves up so that's how you get to become
technically a professional like queen's
gambit but a foosball
yes exactly like you neglect your pets
and you go over there
get high yeah take a bunch of pills
can you be high in a tournament do they
do they drug test for foosball
oh my god there's definitely no drug
testing i think a lot of people are on
different things i couldn't get high and
play foosball because it's so it's such
a fast sport there's a lot of hand-eye
coordination um that i try not to drink
or smoke before before tournaments have
you uh have you one have you won
foosball tournaments
i have yeah my mom and i won women's
expert doubles in vegas a few years ago
together so that was really fun
uh yeah just been playing my whole life
isn't that gonna be exciting man that
you and your mom are together playing in
a tournament and you guys win
it's the best yeah that was definitely a
highlight of my life absolutely and your
mom and your mom is is there a position
are there two positions when you play
are there like a like basketball like a
guard and a forward or
yeah so people either prefer to play
forward or goalie if you're playing
doubles so i typically like to play
forward and my mom likes to play goalies
so that's why it's it's nice to play
together as a team wow
and is she a good she's a good goalie i
would assume
she's the best i mean she's in the
foosball hall of fame so
you don't get in there
just being a [ __ ] player she's she's
really put her time and she's been
playing for over 40 years and where is
the foosball hall of fame located
it's in vegas it doesn't um when i tell
people it's in vegas it's not like
there's an actual
standing hall of fame that's always
there but every year they do the big
hall of fame tournament there and then
they put the banners up and whatever
ballroom of a hotel that we're doing so
if i went over there
and during the day i said i want to go
to the foosball hall of fame they're
like no that it's not up yet yeah
yeah i know it's it's very seasonal it's
one week a year
but you know wherever they have it they
should hang banners i think right
yeah good for championship banners at
least hang banners
yeah i agree so that when you go in
there you can look up sure because
listen
i always tell so i always tell athletes
when i see them
or whoever when they're when they're
champions i say to them
once a champion
always a champion
and they appreciate it because it takes
a lot to to become a champion at
anything it takes a lot
and if anybody wins man it's like hey
you're a champion that's there's a lot
there's a lot to that
definitely yeah i've i've got my
trophies up
they look very quite trash all foosball
trophies have like a lot of flames on
them and stuff like that i see one can
you see it can we
can we see a foosball trophy
they are actually where you guys are
they're at the all things comedy studio
because that's where we shoot wrists of
fury so you might have to have aaron
show you your errands
go grab one
and bring a nice one
[Laughter]
um how was your childhood uh um because
your parents are still married right
no they're they're not together
foosball's not a solid foundation to
build a marriage
[Laughter]
they did their best
but but they but are they friends
friends is a strong word i wouldn't
you know what my wife my ex-wife said to
me last week
i just want us to be friends
and i'm like you know ann i wouldn't
even [ __ ] be your friend because you
you don't have any of the attributes i
for at a friend
there's a friend always somebody that's
it up your ass in your business and why
are you doing that i don't think so not
any friends i have yeah see i'm lucky he
called me a friend
yeah right yeah
i have a bit in my act right now about
that it's so weird to try to be friends
with an ex and that like when i
saw one of my exes a year ago and we
were trying to be friends he fist bumped
me
and i was like oh i would rather have
you fist me like that's just
what's this right here for the yeah for
the listening audience we just got the
the the trophies in here we got oh my
trophy
all right this one here
that that's like a straight up ash tray
like look how bad that looks
it might be a straight up pasture but
but it says
money ball eight
2019
woman's singles second place
i have a lot of second place trophies i
have trouble closing the [ __ ] happened
what uh um what
do you have a lot of second place
trophies
i do i really do i it's like i
am good enough that i get to the finals
and then i get second
way more frequently than i get first i
don't know what happens i just choke do
you have a rival or something is it
someone the same person who's always
beating you or is it it's the field
there's a girl who has she's beaten me
twice
she's really good there's video of it on
youtube actually it's got like a bunch
of views now which is so funny because
it's
like if you google me it's all comedy
clips and then there's this very serious
foosball match where like nobody's
talking it's very queen's gambit like
you mentioned george
the foosball tournaments are very
serious
is is there moves in foosball like does
she have a is there a signature move or
is there a strategy of of moving the
foosball around
yeah we
most of us have our favorite shots that
we go to some i shoot a push shot um but
when you're playing against somebody you
try to figure out early on in the game
what they prefer to shoot so that you
can try to defend against that the most
efficient way so then you have to make
them try to shoot something that's
a shot they're not as comfortable with
so
the old chicano way of having just the
person spin keep spinning around
to block something as you're moving them
you just kind of spit that that can the
foosball player i would assume can't
spin continuously
like his his feet can't go in a circle i
would say right
right so it can't go further than a 360
degree rotation you can't spin the rods
um there's a shot called a rollover
where you pin the ball
with the the foot of the man and then
you roll it over and catch it and you
hit the ball really hard that way and it
prevents it from going a full like past
360. so that's about as far as you can
go ah
that's a good move right there
and then you
with your wrists you just push it back i
spent six months in germany and
everywhere you went they had those
football machines that was the big
pastime over there
and they got yeah great very big in
germany yeah great players over there
i was never that good where did it
originate
um
i'm trying to think if it was in europe
before it was here
but there was a really big boom of it in
the 80s because before then it was
mostly just
pool tables and darts but then they
brought foosball tables in and it became
a huge sport for a while and then
like pac-man machines and stuff like
that started to get moved into bars and
it became a little less popular but for
a while people were making a lot of
money at fooseball tournaments and you
could win
sports cars if you got first place it
was a really big thing for a while
definitely in europe before they came in
i was in germany
uh in the late 60s
oh okay yeah i came over here and you
couldn't
fooseball nobody knew what you were
talking about and you didn't see him
anywhere and he got the boy i actually
bought at one time i had a i had a
football sheena machine in my house i
had the game in my house for a while
i loved it
my wrists were never quick enough to
snap is is the foosball made out of what
material is it um
what is it made out of like the same
thing that maybe a pool
a pool ball would be made out of no
uh
it's a hard plastic it's a real heart
why don't we ask
woman's second place champion
[Laughter]
i've lost all my credibility i gotta
stop saying that
i've never done a podcast right but like
oh yeah you can go get my trophies and
as soon as i said that i was like god
but they say second place that was a
[ __ ] mistake what does that one say
right now second place two girl what is
it if that was a second place
this is
it doesn't look like a monster
second place doesn't it yeah doesn't
that one does that one say second place
too
lot of flames for second place though
good looking trophy flames
really guy fiery vibe with a lot of the
freestyle trousers i want to get back
what is the ball made of
the ball man that i don't know that's a
good question i don't technically know
what that material is just give that a
quick google actually and it literally
says hard plastic which exactly you said
or cork those are the two things that
they're commonly made of i would imagine
most of them are hard plastic i'm going
to tell you hard plastic and cork are
two different games
this one if the price winner didn't know
it the mexican did
[Laughter]
yeah you do if you are going to buy one
you do want one that is
because like you could get one at costco
that's a flimsy piece of [ __ ] and that's
not a real foosball table you want to
get the ones that have a lot of weight
to them and are high quality yeah
okay
how did how did um
how did you find stand up
so i um i was about halfway through
college and
i initially thought i wanted to be a
high school math teacher which now
sounds like you
could not pay me enough money to do that
but
i started to do
monthly open mics
at my college
and it just
stuck i'd always loved making friends
laugh and making my family laugh but um
i was really freaked out to try to
pursue
a career that had such little stability
and little
um security i mean it
it's not like nursing some of my friends
so many of my friends became nurses and
that's such a laid out path where it's
like well you go to this school and then
you do this program and then you
generally get a job with comedy like to
tell my parents i was going to try to
pursue comedy they're just like
no like what why would my daughter try
to be a clown for a living it's just
such an
unstable
business but um i started doing it and
some doors were opening to the point
where i could feel my family be like oh
okay this maybe this will work out and
then
um
i did the seattle scene for a few years
and once i moved to la i started opening
on tour for jim norton and that was
really what helped
me start doing it full time and then
started headlining after that but yeah
jim norton i always call him my like
comedy fairy godmother i didn't know
that that's
who would do that in my life
he really changed my life i don't think
jim norton's ever been called a fairy
godmother
yep
my special fairy godmother but so you
were you were
i would say to fit jim you were probably
edgy
um were you
yeah
i was both i mean i've done
the tonight show and
things where you have to be completely
squeaky clean i work colleges still
so i always wanted to be able to do both
so i can be clean but i also
i feel like in my headlining act if you
come see me
maybe half of it is
more on the edgy dirty end and then half
of it is just not but it's a little bit
of both there was a uh
there was a comedian that had a
television show that was a family show
and i was at the improv one night and i
ran into him outside and he had a yellow
you know legal pad and i said what are
you working on he goes oh you know
my television show is about
as a family show so i don't want to
disappoint anybody that wants to come
and see me
so i'm working on being clean and he
wasn't really clean
uh it's
a bit edgy but i thought that he
made a mistake in trying so i didn't
have my show yet
but i got in the car and i said well if
i ever get a television show
i don't think i'm going to take that
route i think i'm just going to be
what i am and then in the beginning it
will take a little bit of you know
getting used to but
whenever somebody would give me [ __ ]
about being blue or being adult or
not being the way i was on tv i would
say well
that guy got this guy his tv show so
[ __ ] deal with it
you know yeah you know exactly yeah you
know you have a brother that's a [ __ ]
crazy [ __ ] and a brother that's
a good guy well that's the brother
that's [ __ ] crazy and then the guy at
abc is the good guy he's the good
brother
and then it all kind of uh
um and then when they syndicated and all
the kids could watch it i was at the
dodge theater and i just saw that i was
there all the time i did the america's
mexican in there the hbo thing and then
little girls would come and they'd bring
their parents and i was like they're
like hey man a lot of these kids are
coming and and you know and i was like
oh [ __ ] dude like how many out there
so so i said br ask their parents to
bring all the kids back here
and i brought them back there and they
were before the show and they're all
happy about all the parents took their
little pictures where they had made me
little notes and i took pictures with
all the kids and then i told their
parents it would probably be a good idea
if you guys didn't see the show but i'll
hang out with the kids here and take
pictures and talk to them and all that
stuff like that and then we did that and
then a little girl wrote me a note that
said you know i'm heather and i'm eight
and when i grow up i want to marry you
because i love you george lopez and i
watch you all the time and i love you
and i said and we'll throw this [ __ ]
tear this note up and throw it away so
that nobody ever finds it on me
or in my luggage
so but but it it didn't take that long
to kind and then i put on the tickets
like
you had to be 18 or over and it just
kind of helped everything between that
time and this point right here
yeah that's nice that you did that with
the kids and with the parents too to let
them know like hey this is going to be
different than
what you think imagine my surprise when
i sold out the hera's uh theater in lake
tahoe and i walk out and there's a kid
in the middle of the front row wearing a
burger king [ __ ] crown
oh no
oh my god he's royalty he gets a little
[ __ ] crown i could see it through the
light and everything i'm like oh my gosh
what a cherry on top and then once like
one of us
kids seem like a kid than that burger
and i said hey your son's a little young
to be in here and then the dad goes he's
hurt worse
[Laughter]
i was like all right well
you're paying for the therapy bills but
i tried
yeah so so um
what do you love about
have you acted have you have you started
to act or do you do you see yourself
um have you created you see an idea of
like creating your own show
yeah um i i did just get um a television
agent fairly recently so i've started to
do more auditioning but i do love to act
i just don't have like
a ton of experience with it um i have my
web series the foosball web series
wrists of fury through all things comedy
and so in terms of a television show
that is something i would love to
have on tv so we're kind of in the
process of working on that but yeah i
would also love to do more acting for
sure well i'm going to give you some i
don't give really good people advice but
i i would say that um is that me that
summon
oh it just went away but i was getting
humming all the [ __ ]
great comedians that come in through
here
this place got the worst [ __ ]
headphones and worst [ __ ]
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's like the playboy mansion well
everything in there is beautiful except
the decor and the owner of the [ __ ]
place
how do you really feel
i told
you the uh uh but but but
i'll always tell people how i really
feel
because i'm divorced i don't have to
[ __ ] lying
the uh um
um
but you have to you i would say get
acting lessons
okay like take acting lessons because
stand up does not make you
an actor it doesn't make you good at
acting
because we wander with our eyes and
we're looking around and it's hard to
look somebody and think and uh
um i don't want to say who who it was
you know but where
i'm shooting a show with my daughter
like a pilot and i've asked a couple of
comedians to come in and guys who are
very successful in podcasts and i would
say that it was not a complicated scene
and they were not very good
and when someone is not very good
it it it stays with the
the the comedian might not realize it
but it stays with the people who see it
and if they go to another show and
they'll say what about uh so-and-so and
they'll say oh you know i saw him and he
wasn't very good so um you know whenever
that day comes that you know you take
that step to be
to be good you know i in in uh
2001 right before we went to christmas
break i read with the guy who ended up
getting my
the best friend job and he was really an
actor and i wasn't and i read within him
i was so [ __ ] bad i looked over at my
partners and they were like this like
because nobody had ever asked me
can you act
and i couldn't i couldn't but then when
i got home i told my manager if i met a
coach and i had a coach with me
102 weeks of 120 shows oh wow wow wow
yeah i i don't think i could have
i don't think i could have done that
show or that show have been successful
had i not have had an acting coach with
me every week
was the coach on set too or was it
something you do like in between no no
on set oh yeah because i was i was uh
you know i was a monotone speaker
and then i was dyslexic and i was an
auditory processor so if i read it i
didn't understand it i had to have
somebody tell it to me and i didn't know
that until
i got an acting coach and she would i
would say read it to me
and she would read it to me and i would
turn my head so only so i could only
hear her
and that's how i
oh
okay really [ __ ] nut job [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i do want to do some acting coaching the
tour schedule right now has been so
insane that i feel like i've been having
to kind of focus on that and my podcast
and mr fury but um i i am very very open
to doing it
are you touring right now are you
touring right now yes
and where can people find you where can
people find you guys or find you so
yeah so i'm i am pretty much in a
different city every week at this point
except for a few weeks off but um i will
be i don't when is this coming out it's
probably about two weeks out from now
two weeks out okay um i'm gonna be um at
the laugh factory in las vegas april 7th
through the 10th
um i'll be in austin april 21st through
the 23rd and
san diego at american comedy company
april 29th through the 30th and
shooting my special at comedy works in
denver on june 18th so if you go to
kelseycook.com you can get tickets for
for a bunch of stuff coming up uh which
one are you shooting it at the one
downtown or the south club
the one downtown yeah
yeah that's a great club
yeah it's so good i did my album there a
few years ago
and uh yeah we're really excited i just
like those low ceilings and just the
crowds in denver it's so great yeah so
wendy curtis who owns the
the uh comedy works over there she
opened one in the south
south course south course
a golfer
and this it's called the sub uh south
club i think
so uh yeah
south so it was going under
it was not going to survive
so i said
i'll go in there and i'll give you all
of the money from all of the shows
and i went in there and i gave her all
the money from all the shows and the
club survived
good for you oh my gosh was this during
uh cobit or is this no way before like
when she started the economy the economy
dropped and it was going to go down and
i and i went in there we've known each
other for
maybe 20 years i think
maybe
maybe yeah and um i gave her all the
money
oh that's really cool you did that and
it stayed open and uh it's still open
you know what amazing i don't know what
the [ __ ] happened to me i used to be i'd
be like [ __ ] that [ __ ] plan
[Laughter]
i i think when you i think when you
really appreciate you know
um
things that happened to you
that you never expected i think your
duty is to pay it forward i think
exactly
for sure you know
so yeah talking about jim being my
comedy fairy godmother like now when i
have my friends featured for me on the
road i'm trying to keep
what he did for me in mind with them and
trying to help them get into
some of the clubs in new york or just
getting people more on the road or
social media it's just
anything that you can do to help pay it
forward i think is important
this podcast is sponsored by better help
online therapy relationships take work a
lot of us will drop anything to go help
someone we care about
we'll go out of our way to treat other
people well but how often do we give
ourselves the same treatment
so i've been in therapy since 2000 and
i've learned a lot of things one of the
things i learned early was that my
grandmother was a bit of a trigger for
me
i also had to learn how to take
responsibility for my own actions and
when i was estranged from my daughter my
therapist told me to keep
calling her even though she didn't
answer so she would know that i did not
give up on her
powerful that's great better health is
an online therapy that offers video
phone and even live chat sessions with
your therapist so you don't have to see
anyone on camera if you don't want to
very important it's much
more what you're comfortable with and
it's more affordable than in-person
therapy and you can be matched with a
therapist in under 48 hours give it a
try and see why over 2 million people
have used better help online
therapy the podcast is sponsored by
betterhelp i want to thank them omg high
with george lopez listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
omghi that's b e
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p-dot-com
o-m-g-h-i and this is what i'll say
about therapy is a lot of times
culturally like people are not into it
or whatever but you know
as you live in life sometimes you'll
make the same mistakes you're not sure
why because you need somebody who's
trained to that to to look from the
outside and say
that it might be this it might be that
if you do this and you do that
a lot of times it's kind of opening a
window that maybe you would never open
on yourself and that goes a long long
way in relationships relationships with
people as you get older and then now you
know a lot of times um
people wait too long and then you can't
say it so say it while you can still
learn it while you can still be
effective and while the person you want
to say it to is still in your life
before they go
amen
enjoy smoking cannabis like never before
with an ice cold freeze pipe freeze pipe
makes a freezable line of pipes bubblers
bongs and more for the coldest and
smoothest smoking experience picture
this it's after dinner
you've survived a long day of work and
hitting the gym and it's time to fire up
netflix
and a fat
bo only problem is your old bong sucks
and leaves you with a scratchy throat
and coughing problem ditch that bong
you've had for for years an upgrade to
an ice-cold freeze pipe
so
i have a great party every summer called
wheat in my pool and
this party will have freeze pipe in it
and i can't wait for my hundreds of
guests to try freeze pipe themselves
because i know one hit
and they'll be that's it
so freeze pipe
awesome i tried it and um
i would always cough right off the bat
like immediately from way way back and
that has not happened and it is
as cool as smoking weed looks
it's cooler when you take that hit down
and it's just like this wonderful when
you go skiing for the first time and
you're outside you're like
just like that beautiful that's what i
like about it the most and it's april
and it means that it's cannabis
christmas
which is 4 20 and freeze pipe is
offering the biggest deals of the year
going on through april 20th and insane
deals
on pipes
bongs dab rings accessories shop 24 7
now at the freezepipe.com but you'll
probably be shopping for like two in the
morning till like five you won't be
shopping during the day when you're at
work i know if you're out there smoking
weight one day hey i call these plants
are still here sorry boss won't you
order online in the middle of night like
all the other marijuanas and if you use
and if you see something you want that's
not on sale use omg high for 10 off
that's the freezepipe.com and use the
code omg hi
for 10 off or shop killer 420 sales
going on right now
the killer sales are going on right now
when you were growing up what did what
did you watch and what did you think was
funny
oh that's a good question
i mean i was
such a big like mtv kid and
nickelodeon and all that stuff so all
that and keenan and kell i remember
really loving those were like very young
years
and then after that
in terms of stand-up um you know dane
cook was so big when i was
like late high school early college
michael biglia
uh dimitri martin jim gaffigan
brian regan you
um really was i was
watching a bunch of stuff and just
loving what i was seeing and just wanted
to get into it did you ever see a guy
does anybody remember a guy named
eddie strange where like from his name
was ross martin from san francisco
no
like i was always
a you know it's funny when i did when i
started to do the jazz festival one of
the jazz guys said now i understand why
you got picked because it's like jazz
like you know all the notes
and you just move around but that's not
being unstructured is not the best
approach to stand up but that guy
eddie strange we were in uh we were in
hawaii at a
at a gentleman's club you know like the
private club you know and where you
could go into a military and you can
watch and they were watching motley
crue's
girls girls girls video
girls girls girls and then the video
started to go up and those guys are like
what the [ __ ] going on the [ __ ] is
this [ __ ]
that guy goes out there and he goes
welcome guys to the listed men's club
it's comedy night [ __ ] that [ __ ]
and we're like whoa and the emcee goes
out there and he goes i'll i'll do a
tight i'll be back in 20 minutes i'll
handle my foot comes back in six minutes
and he's like whoa they're tough and
then i go i was about 25 i did 12.
i got the [ __ ] out of there oh wow and
then eddie strange went up and did his
whole act
and at the end got a standing ovation
and i said to him the next day i said
what the [ __ ] did you do last night how
does that happen
and he says unlike you guys i have an
act
and i did my act and my i trusted that
my act is good enough that however
those guys were or whatever condition
they were in that my act would prevail
over them
and it did
and you know what i did i went to i went
to
i went to the
to the drugstore and got some three by
five cards and started trying to put my
[ __ ] in order
and it's the best thing i ever did the
best thing i ever saw
because scattered you forget it you're
like one joke that's good from five
jokes and it doesn't work now you go
over here and now you got five jokes and
you use two of those five now you got
[ __ ] seven jokes that you can't use
because they're all out of sequence and
you just
so
yeah yeah and we don't know what
happened to that guy does he he's
doing stand-ups
what's going on with eddie
eddie strange but he was awesome yeah he
was awesome any of those guys that you
see that
you know i think dane cook suffered from
i think ego and i think you know from
being the first to kind of do it by
facebook and stuff right
mm-hmm right yeah but by space even in
my space right but what he was doing
he was he was uh he was great he was
great
yeah that was
my at my age um when he was really
really huge and started to do the arenas
and
everything
that was the first time that i had seen
that happening and i know that people
before him were doing it but i think for
my generation he was really impactful
yeah definitely it's it's a it's a big
deal and you know there really isn't any
you know the one thing that that is a
great about stand-up is there really
isn't any rules to it you know the the
the only if whether you you know the
only rule that i think anybody would
like to have is you know just be funny
you know just just you know that's how
you get to
you know i remember somebody walking in
and saying is this guy funny
and the other person would go well
uh he'd go put his hand behind his ear
and you'd go well you tell me
yeah but but there is kind of a um
there is kind of a
i would say killer be killed mentality
that
what any comedian has to have in order
to be consistently good right
for sure yeah i think
this business
you can get weeded out pretty quickly if
if you're consistently not doing well on
stage
it's so much
word of mouth i think in this business
to get
on stage and keep going that
you know i think you can go to those
smaller scenes and see those local
comics who basically just continue to do
the open mics or
shows that don't require
somebody booking you you could just sign
up and go up um and like you can people
can just get caught up in that loop
because
maybe it's not the thing that they're
meant to do but yeah you
you have to keep getting better in this
business i think or else you get weeded
out pretty quickly there was a couple
things that i don't think you could do
anymore there was a disabled comedian
that was working at the lab factory one
time and it took him a while to get up
and it took him a little while to get
off
and i was next and i said man i feel bad
i'm in that dude's parking spot
[Laughter]
you know what i mean like i would just
do the [ __ ] that
would just be like ah you know and i
would never tell anybody
whether i would do it or not i would
just do it and just let it let the
[ __ ] chips fall where they may you
know
at some point you're like you know i
remember there was a native american
woman that was in the front and i said
why wouldn't we want when we i wouldn't
want to be buying your drinks
[Laughter]
and she got up and left and she goes
i'll have a margarita
is she bringing drinks i mean you know
so so what is your um is there a mantra
or what is your approach or what do you
like to tell yourself
um you know as you as we dig into this
[ __ ] crazy ass business of just
you know and then you know people are
like you know the world needs laughter
[ __ ] laughter the world needs everybody
to just [ __ ] mind their own [ __ ]
business before it needs laughter
but what's the approach that uh
that that you that you take that you
like
i feel like for me the easiest way i've
learned to write jokes is just observing
what's happening in my life or within my
friends lives and i feel like it has
become almost more story based over time
not it doesn't have to have to
necessarily be like a long story but
just
taking things that are happening in my
real life i've become a big fan
of
taking things that would otherwise be
embarrassing or maybe
something that makes you feel
ashamed and that you wouldn't want to
talk about with people and trying to
take those things and talk about them on
stage because
then people
i'm always amazed at how many people
come to me after they're like oh my god
thank you so much for talking about that
i'm so much less embarrassed can you
stop can you say that can you say what
it is
oh yeah i mean there
there are a few things like well my
my first comedy central credit was on
this is not happening
talking about the first time i tried
masturbating ending up in the emergency
room because i thought i had a latex
allergy that way
so that yeah
i have
i have ibs and at one point living with
my um
one of my exes we
only had one bathroom
and uh
he was like in there doing what you
dudes usually do which is like taken for
[ __ ] ever in the bathroom
and um i just sometimes when you have
ibs you just there's no
there's no stopping it and i just like
had to
poop in a cardboard box in my living
room and
that
story is online and
um but i'm telling you like when i share
those sort of stories i get so many
people that are like oh my god like
i also had to [ __ ] in an amazon box in
my in my living room and it was so
horrifying
whatever it is that's why you get the
cats for the litter box just like this i
know yeah
trust me everybody after i've shared
that story everybody's like why didn't
you just shoot in the litter box i'm
like goddamn it i didn't even think of
that
yeah
i'm not happy about that but well you
know somebody said to me you know do you
date and i'm like uh
why don't you somebody said to me why
don't
why don't you date somebody your own age
and i said
have you seen [ __ ] people my own age
oh boy look
i said that women have won like i have
no desire to to date
i have no desire to be interested in
somebody that i'm trying to be
interested in i have no desire to listen
to a woman speak to me
about maintaining a relationship or
forging a relationship and i said and if
there's a and if dick tastes like
chicken i'm getting in that line
i've had i was never good at being with
women i was never
and i'm a sweet dude but i just have
just [ __ ] had it
it's so funny you're just like so
close-minded in certain ways and you're
so open-minded in other words you're
like i'm not dating a chick my age but i
will suck a dick
that's such a strange dichotomy i'll be
60 in march give me a dick over here
one that tastes like chicken if it
tastes like chicken i wouldn't and a
good chicken
i mean dinosaurs
let me save you the dick
it doesn't oh man
yeah
but you and and and uh i think when like
young girls like you know when they see
an old dude like an old dude can't have
game to unless there's daddy issues
right
i mean i might as well walk
if a guy is not attractive but he's
older you're saying that there has to be
like some sort of money involved yeah
yeah i almost want to be like
any women have daddy issues in here
we're over here
we're very wealthy and we're working
hard on the ice but
if you got daddy issues wander over
ladies
yeah i mean they're i think of like anna
nicole smith right that that marriage
years and years ago where you're like
there's something happening here that is
not normal
yeah that's that's
that's
the money grab but i'm talking about
like
if you're if you had a friend that was
dating a person who was maybe 20 years
or 20 or more than 20 years older would
you feel would you feel comfortable in
telling her like
uh what's going on over here with uh
you know
i mean over 20 there's something to that
that's like that's a lot that is a lot
but i mean i listen
i'm a female comic i have my share of
daddy issues so i feel like i can't
really [ __ ] on anybody else i have like
just enough
that i became a comic but like not
enough that i became a stripper like i
feel like i can't like got right in the
middle
but it's a careful balance but you know
if you're the funniest stripper
there's some pretty good there's money
in there you can clean up you know when
uh when i went to tijuana we uh in the
early 80s the guys i grew up with
we were taking we were taking clothes to
his relatives in in in tijuana
and they put them in these like paint
bin all the clothes in there and as soon
as we get on the 118 freeway
we hear
and we're like what the [ __ ] and this
car comes alongside of us rolls the
windows down he goes pull over and we
pull over at all of the [ __ ] clothes
have [ __ ] left the luggage rack and
they're in the on the 118 freeway yeah
and you see cars going by going ah and
it's scraping the barrel all the clothes
are in the freeway
and literally we're not 20 minutes away
from the family that that that gave us
the clothes to take to the people of
mexico and then the guy says well what
do you want to do man you want to just
say [ __ ] it and i said no man let's go
to [ __ ] tijuana [ __ ] the clothes
i said we'll buy some [ __ ] clothes
over there what the [ __ ] it's [ __ ]
tijuana how much can clothes be
so
we were we were in a strip club and and
the two dancers were there were were
very attractive you know and my friend
next to me flock with this guy george
you know he was there and the third girl
comes out and she's very kind of like a
beat up jennifer beals
like from flash dance you know jennifer
beals from flash dance is beautiful
and but this one looked like a beat up
hard version of jennifer beals with
curly hair
and
when she walked out my friend laughed
i didn't laugh but he couldn't stop
laughing so she's dancing around over
here and she had like no titties but
like her nipples were like
that long like long oh boy
so she danced over
and she looked at him and she squeezed
her nipple and a stream of milk
flew through the air
and [ __ ] landed across his face
i didn't get hit by any straight milk
because i didn't laugh but
she went like this and she sniped him
and you could see it in the air and
[ __ ] it went like and he looked at me
oh my god
so if i ever do it if i ever do a movie
good for her if i ever do a movie that's
in the
there you go if i ever write a movie
that's in the movie
absolutely yeah
but but
i'll just sit there and let it fall
across me but
but in comedy it's like you have to see
some
you have to see some amazing [ __ ] like
that in order to like just put
everything in this reservoir don't you
think
yeah for sure you have to go out and
live and yeah i think it's easy when
you're on tour to get into a cycle of
just
landing going to the hotel doing your
shows and just repeating that but you
have to still go out and do things
because you need new experiences to
write about we had a guy that steve
lopez and we
in high school he would always see us he
and he'd go like that
and he put his hand over his
we'd go steve
that's how you knew it was stevie he'd
go
so we were in tijuana and we're going
into this this this nightclub and the
doors open and these bouncers throw a
[ __ ] guy down the stairs oh
they got him by the like the back of his
belt and his shoulders and they throw
this [ __ ] dude and he lands on our
feet and it's steve he looks up and goes
i swear to god
in [ __ ] tijuana
and he lands on our feet
and goes
i mean
i think your movie's writing itself i
already have two scenes that connect to
each other we do
got breast milk sniper
and your friend with a weird sound
effect
oh man
uh um the girls that you grew up with
are you still friends with them
yes i i feel super fortunate my best
friends are friends of like 25 years so
um
love them very much i think it's also
like i have best friends that are also
comedians but i think it's nice to have
a core group of people in your life that
are not in this business because
again it's it can be very all-consuming
and i think it's important to still have
people that remind you what life is like
outside of this very weird world you
know i'm going to say that you know i've
been watching a lot of youtube and
a lot of the influencers on youtube
when when things don't work out for them
or they use their their power for ill
not and not just for entertainment
and
and because
if money comes to them
it comes fast but they really haven't
earned it and i think it's a little bit
of
like
i think it's fraudulent because they
really haven't
really done something for a long amount
of time
to where you are your stripes but
there's very few people who are
comedians that go on the road
and tour and travel
that that happens to because you have a
[ __ ] bottom
and you have a yeah and you haven't hit
your top but you have a bottom they
start where they're like making some
money
and getting paid to post but there's no
bottom and they and they hit the bottom
so you know for comedians and you know
like you traveling and like us traveling
that all of those things man
unbeknownst to any of us really
kind of temper you to where you're
prepared for almost anything
i agree i think the only times you
really see that now with comics is if
somebody
hits it really big on tick tock but they
don't actually have stand-up experience
and all of a sudden they're able to
start selling out theaters but they
don't have
10 years
under their belt of actual writing or
going through hard [ __ ] but yeah i
i i am this is my 13th year of standup
and i am so grateful that it actually
has taken a long time because i
appreciate everything
right now because i do remember
those years of
making like zero money and it's just
it's not a very glamorous
it is life until you can potentially
make it in a bigger way and you and you
don't really know
what somebody's going through you know
or don't you don't know
because there's really not that shared
kind of life
uh thing i don't think you know there
was a guy
um i think his name
i i don't know his name and
you know he dressed like a comic you
know he had the knitted tie and he was
very clean
but he was an alcoholic and i mean he
was an alcoholic like this dude was like
drunk 24 hours a day
but to the point where he was a
functioning alcoholic i guess you would
call him but he was clean he didn't look
dirty he was clean he would do his act
and on you know we were at the head we
were at harrah's in vegas and there was
like monday through sunday two shows a
night uh [ __ ] the worst [ __ ] place
in the world
and um and he hit he'd hit you up for
money
on monday you know on tuesday
and uh
we i saw him before the holidays one
year
and he went back to houston and he hung
himself outside of a hotel um
oh my god before his family was going to
come and pick him up
and um
you just
never know what
i mean that dude never said hey man you
guys want to go out and eat you guys
want to go and talk we didn't see him
before the show and then right after the
show was over and i mean you know
there's people out there
that are you know comics that you know
they're they're they're rough especially
now that there's less places to to kind
of go so
you know yeah being appreciative of
being able to walk on a stage and
entertain people is
is uh is a good idea because you know
you know that i mean you're going to be
a math teacher it's like
that was that was the evil that you're
like i don't want to do that but there's
a freedom
that we can talk right now there's a
freedom to this that you know that when
you're done with us that you have your
day like there's a freedom to that
and that's a freedom that you can't put
a price on
yeah i think a lot of people aren't
willing to invest
those years of it being a very
unglamorous life and not making much
money um for the potential payoff
because i know people in my life who are
so funny and who did have dreams of
wanting to
maybe be a comic but
they
kind of got in that
rut of working
corporate jobs that didn't fulfill them
in uh you know an emotional way but
financially they felt really secure and
they never wanted to walk away from that
so i i feel lucky that i started at 20
because i didn't ever really get to
experience financial security when i was
younger it was just like i'm just going
to pursue
this thing that i love
but um
yeah you do
you do come to appreciate even though
there are a lot of hard years that
freedom is it's invaluable it's so nice
um
i guess none of my business but do you
still have ibs
[Laughter]
such a beautiful life path and you're
like do you [ __ ] your pants still
but you know it's like i play jazz i
just go with the notebook
they're all over the place yeah i used
to work with a dude that played that
idbs in the early 80s and he and this
guy was a little dude there was richard
millard and he sounded like elmer fudd
he's like have you guys seen my cabin
leo he bought a cavalier a chevy
cavalier
and i didn't know anything about him and
when you would be in the bathroom and if
you saw those boots you got like almost
like birds in the tree they got
they got the [ __ ] out of there man are
you going it's so funny you'd run out
and you were still buckling your [ __ ]
pants
and women would be you'll be like their
workstations and they knew they knew
like if richard walks in there get the
[ __ ] out of there
no oh my god so funny i feel like mine
is more just
like it seems like people who don't have
ibs
can feel
gill's getting ready for the epic
you know
i think people that don't have ibs have
a longer grace period from when they can
start to feel like oh i think i need to
go
to then like
like if they're on a road trip or
something they're like i think i need to
go if i find somewhere in the next hour
cool
for me it's like if i feel like i need
to go i gotta like find somewhere
is it really a reasonable amount of time
listen man
[ __ ] in little league bro nobody want to
pee on my kids
we were digging up child trauma
and that was good
you know wherever we played i had to be
near where the bathroom was by
the you know third base line i was a
third baseman or one i was a right
fielder and they go yo they got eight
players now he'll be back
but it's i don't know what it's tied to
you know whether it's tied to
and i've [ __ ] up my back and everything
you know
oh boy i mean
not like dudes would be like hey that's
my man hey [ __ ] don't talk that [ __ ] to
him everybody's gone man
you have to wait till it gets dark
before you can walk you gotta [ __ ]
[ __ ] all over your [ __ ] uniform
i ain't never gonna be able to look at
you the same
but no but i mean it's
is it is it tied to stress is it is it
is it tied to stress or
i think it's yeah i'm sure
having a stressful lifestyle or
having anxiety doesn't help also if
you're actively on tour that is hard on
your body to be on a plane every week
like that pressure
in the air and just being
indifferent
but if you're a math teacher you'll be
like all right students here's the
problem oh and you guys just work on
this
that is amazing to me that teachers
are like [ __ ] you are kind of in a
hostage situation every hour for an hour
if you have to go that's a problem it
yeah it is a problem it is a problem
it is a problem oh my god
and you know i think ips
is worse than irritable bowels i think
if somebody would say irritable i have
irritable bowel syndrome and they're
like oh my god that must be
awful to live with and then you go ahead
every word of that is terrible yeah and
then you have ibs hey man
you know
don't come in get off my little league
team
you're going to be the only boy without
a number
your number's going to be i ibs on the
back number two yeah you're number two
for sure uh uh is it in the does it is
it in the family i don't know
does it run in the family
it's just i don't think it's just
foosball
why do you think your parents got
divorced
that's not why
but if you're playing foosball and it
hits you and then like you know that's
why the mom's the goalie i think it
wasn't
like [ __ ] 11
hey welcome back it's [ __ ] 11-1
[Laughter]
we're dying over here um
no no i mean it's nothing to laugh i
mean it's nothing laughable
i've been down the road myself i'm
sitting in an amazon box in my living
room if i didn't want to laugh about it
like it's way better off about it but
but isn't it way better to laugh about
it than it is to to to just pretend like
you know because there are people out
there that
you know i i had kidney disease i went
to bed growing up and i did a show about
it where i gave it to my whatever issue
i had i gave it to my son and then ken
howard the white shadow played the
doctor so i used all kidney related
people you know and i got a lot of nice
we got a lot of nice you know messages
from people who if if a kid
listen my grandma my grandmother raised
me she didn't [ __ ] with the bed
she'd be like look at that [ __ ]
french toast over here on this
[ __ ] mattress
and i've been just off just awful you
know then they would say like you know
don't drink water after five george you
know don't drink water after three then
they got don't drink water in may
[ __ ] just a severe yeah
and i was [ __ ] up i had a bad kid i
had an issue with my kidneys and i had a
transplant but i think if
you grow up with people that don't make
fun of [ __ ] everybody for having
something wrong with them i might have i
might have saved my kidneys i'm pretty
sure
oh
yeah
way better to talk about yeah it is way
better to talk about it and what and
whatever it is you know in comedy it's
like
that's it's the it's the diffuser of of
of things
i did a thing i had a show where danny
trail was my uncle he had never got a
prostate exam and i told him that we
were going to a corvette show
and it was really
it was really a
urologist
because it had a long thing in the in
the in the uh he goes what's this george
i said this is the design room you know
they had a long thing and i go oh that's
the new bumper that's a new bumper of
the corvette he's like wow that thing's
sleek and uh and he got he got in there
they they checked them but i had to i
had to lie to him to get him to get a
prostate exam oh my goodness and and i
mean when you make [ __ ] when you make
fun of it no i certainly make fun of it
but when you bring it to
light with humor
it's much better than
than it is
to
um
to be to be ignored i would say
yeah i think it i think you take back
your power in those situations if you
can be the one
talking about it
and joking about it then it i think it
does take away some of that shame and
like i said it's so fun for me to have
other people come up and share their
experiences with those things with me
and say that they appreciate hearing
other people talk about because then
they feel less embarrassed
you know you know [ __ ] you've
never been on stage you don't know about
that [ __ ] i'll just nod
but but you what you just but you know
what you know what that is right there's
idiosyncracies that you have that i have
that during the day
um
we just have to a different mind mindset
during the day than someone else
yeah i agree i do think we try to maybe
be more observant
of our weird [ __ ] than the average
person because we are looking for like
could this be something we talk about on
stage that people could relate to do you
do you um
when you when you or do you have a
routine like you sleep do you take a nap
during the afternoon or
are you awake or how's your thing
yeah i do try to take a nap now in the
afternoon um especially because if
you're at clubs and you're doing two
shows a night by the end of the night
you've done like two hours on stage
which is a long time
so i do try to take a nap i try to
work out in the hotel gyms now which is
something i never used to do but now
it's just become like an important part
of trying to feel good on the road
so yeah those are kind of my two two big
things i try to do is work out a nap
yeah
uh
when i was uh during the whole trump
thing you know i would i would be in the
hotels and i saw i've been swimming for
a while you know
and uh
i was swimming one day and i got out and
someone said uh oh george lopez i didn't
know you were a swimmer i said the way
shit's going i might have to go back
and i always tried to swim when there
was nobody around like they go the pool
opens at five in the morning i'll be
there at 505. yeah i didn't want anybody
i didn't want anybody running into me
when i was swimming
but
but i i i was i've been sleeping from
like
you know three to six uh from for as
long as i can remember and i think you
know that's part of the whole
the whole thing about you know being
having a routine and stuff
yeah it's super important
yeah and if you can take a red eye [ __ ]
don't ever take a red eye
never
oh my god never
i took a radar to dc and did
constitution hall and we're supposed to
have the table read for that show at one
o'clock and i was not
of course i ate a gummy on the airplane
i was not out i was not in condition to
i would say to
to have been alert enough so no more red
eyes for me i i that's like no
yeah that's awesome hard line for me i
won't do them anymore i did years ago
and i just can't now yeah and how does
jim tour does he he flies you know
commercial he does all that huh
yeah um i mean it's been a few years
since i was torn with him but when we
did tour yeah it was uh um we would
usually take like the first flight out
uh which i do think is smart because if
there are delays
at least you're not dealing with that
later on in the day but yeah pretty
standard
yeah we uh we were in dc and then it was
uh we got snowed out of dc so we drove
to philadelphia which was a couple of a
couple of hours but we were already at
the airport and they canceled the
flights on and
so we
we took a suv to philadelphia yeah
yeah yeah so much crazy travel [ __ ] that
we run into
every week you're always just at the
mercy of airlines
do you see yourself
do you see yourself doing stand-up like
in it for eternity or i would say
eternity i mean i've been doing a long
time but but do you see
do you see an end to it or are you just
going to do it until you just it's what
you love to do
it's what i love to do i
would imagine i would be doing it for
the rest of my life i can't picture not
doing it
i think to be this far in at this point
and still loving it so much is i think a
good sign so yeah i can't picture not
doing it
uh do you uh do you smoke marijuana do
you use marijuana i do i do edibles
um
because you know you usually podcasts um
you know they
they usually have like a t-shirt they
give to somebody and we didn't do that
so i was thinking like how could i
you know
how would i give my guests that
so i i used to do this while i do this
party at my house called who weed in my
pool party
and everybody everybody that's been on
the podcast when i get a date we'll be
invited to this party hell yeah oh fun
okay and there's a swimming pool and
there's celebrities and there's porn
stars
and there's bands
and great food
and musicians and guys that just it's
just the best
it's just the best group of people
that cedric the entertainer goes you'll
go on one room and eddie van halen will
be in there and you go another room and
the [ __ ] geico lizards and
it's like i know i know so many people
and it's one of those it was made to be
like that party that
would just everybody could be anybody
and be there and and be cool
amazing well i would love to go yeah
that sounds great thank you and it's not
that it's not that anybody needs to
smoke or not it's just
you know it's about time it's just a
good time yeah yeah yeah yeah
so uh well i would love that
thanks for having me oh yeah of course
gil um it's all over for you anyways i'm
just happy being your brother so you
know so you know gil was one of the
detectives that caught uh richard
ramirez the night stalker
amazing wow that's so cool
thank you for doing that oh you're very
welcome i didn't think she was old
enough to even know but he's letting a
lot of [ __ ] go um
when you go to those seminars and you go
to the seminars what's what's the what's
the what do people want to know from you
as you were los angeles dodgers your
[ __ ] shade
ushers don't wear this hey we're back
and we're back in business that's why i
wore it that's there we go all right can
we find my seed later we uh we we talked
about the biggest question they asked
nature nurture
was he born like that or did
yeah you know did it come along later on
and
you know what was he really like you
know was he
demonic you know and what was it like
going in to talk to the guy and
stuff like that what do you say nature
or nurture comedians can you can you
teach somebody
those instincts that make a comedian
great or is it or is it
that's a good question that's a good
question i think it's i think it's
probably more nature than nurture but i
think i think people can learn
techniques that would make them better
on stage absolutely
but i think you gotta have a little bit
of trauma
the way i laugh today
the way you hear me laugh today
i can remember since i was a kid my mom
was always giving me chin gossip
because i couldn't stop laughing yeah
you know
that that came since i was a kid
amazing uh um
you have said do you have siblings did i
ask if you had siblings
um you haven't no i i have a younger
brother
um
and a younger stepsister and a younger
half brother so just a mess of a family
but you know everything's good yeah yeah
and and when you were growing up your
parents were they were they nurturing to
you or
would you spend any time alone or
yeah no they were nurturing i was i was
really lucky i mean obviously
witnessing your parents go through a
divorce is uh hard and there were a lot
of hard times with that but i was very
fortunate both of my parents
have always
shown me unconditional love and been
very
um
just outwardly loving you know what i
mean i've never questioned if they love
me and i know that that's not always the
case and so i do feel very lucky uh can
they be together in the same room now i
think yeah they can be in the same room
that's you know that that's a tough one
for us who's a better football player
dad or mom
oh you're trying to start some [ __ ]
my family christmas is tough i don't
know i really couldn't tell you they're
both still very good
um
but i'm so sorry to do this i have to i
have to run to an appointment um but is
there a way that we can like wrap up in
a normal way that doesn't sound abrupt
yeah like that
okay all right
uh do you wanna tell the people where to
find you your socials all that sort of
stuff anything to promote risk fury
yeah um please watch the fury it's my
football web series on youtube through
through all things comedy um you can
yeah you can go to kelseycook.com for
tour tickets and you can follow me on
instagram and tick tock at all i'm sorry
at kelsey cook comedy on both of those
yeah all right kelsey cook thanks for
coming by thank you for coming i hope
that you enjoyed yourself and you're not
kidding anybody ibs is kicking in that's
why you gotta go
[Laughter]
yeah i have an appointment have you ever
forget about the abrupt
thank you very much for sharing your
time with us thank you guys for having
me
you